nous sommes tellement habitués d'avoir
des emballages dans nos vies que nous ne
les voyons même plus ils accompagnent
chacun de nos gestes du quotidien ils
sont partout et on les prend pour acquis
pour constater à quelqu'un la Semaine
québécoise de réduction des déchets
commence aujourd'hui avec pour thème
repenser pour mieux réduire et c'est
exactement ce à quoi invite un
documentaire mis en ligne aujourd'hui
par écho-entreprise Québec avec l'école
de design de Lucam le film tout déballé
lève le voile sur le système complexe de
production de consommation qui se cache
derrière l'emballage avec nous Sylvain
alors il est professeurs directeur de
programme du design graphique de l'UQAM
co-réalisateur d'ailleurs du
documentaire bonsoir Monsieur alors
documentaire très intéressant monsieur
alors mais pourquoi vous avez décidé
d'en faire un sur ce sujet là pourquoi
se concentrer sur l'emballage mais
d'abord c'est mon champ de recherche et
mon chat mon champsupiler c'est ce que
j'enseigne mais aussi parce que c'est un
objet vernaculaire qui est partout
autour de nous tout le monde a des
emballages tout le monde vit chaque jour
avec les emballages et je trouvais
intéressant de faire un documentaire qui
s'adressait au grand public pour sortir
un peu de l'université puis de faire un
peu l'état des lieux de ce qui se passe
avec cet objet là qui nous pose des qui
nous donne les services mais qui nous
posent des petits problèmes aussi qui
mène à une certaine prise de conscience
quand on voit dans le documentaire les
images de dépotoires là c'est l'ampleur
du problème le suremballage que vous
montrez du doigt d'ailleurs oui le
problème de l'emballage c'est c'est
complexe parce que autant on en a besoin
autant c'est nécessaire dans nos vies
actuelles autant effectivement il y a
toutes sortes de choses qui se fait puis
c'est pas tout à fait contrôler donc on
a des bons emballages des moins bons
emballages et puis on s'y perd un peu le
consommateur super d'ailleurs vous dites
dans le dans le documentaire parce que
le plastique est souvent montré du doigt
mais vous dites le plastique c'est pas
ça le problème c'est l'utilisation du
plastique pourquoi vous laissez entendre
ça le plastique est le problème
lorsqu'il se retrouve dans
l'environnement mais lorsqu'il est
recyclé utiliser sous une matière qui a
quand même beaucoup beaucoup d'avantages
et qui peut pas se comparer
nécessairement à d'autres matières qui
sont soit plus lourdes ou soit plus
difficile à produire le plastique offre
beaucoup beaucoup d'avantages mais le
problème c'est que lorsqu'on l'utilise
pour des usages uniques qu'on le jette
dans l'environnement on le jette tout
simplement mais c'est là qu'il y a des
chances de se retrouver dans
l'environnement et c'est ça qu'il
faudrait faire la part des choses je
pense vous mettez en lumière le fait que
c'est une matière durable avec un usage
éphémère c'était vraiment une
présentation intéressante et là vous
laissez entendre évidemment c'est un peu
votre rôle la solution elle se trouve en
amont d'ailleurs le bas était d'accord
avec ça un système de ces
recommandations quand on s'est penché
sur la gestion des résidus ultimes l'an
dernier alors comment l'éco-conception
ce que vous enseignez d'ailleurs ça
permet d'aider à régler le problème en
partie mais c'est sûr qu'on peut se
navrer devant des résultats de
d'emballage qui se retrouvent dans
l'environnement mais moi mon travail de
designer c'est en amont que ça se passe
c'est à dire avant que les emballages
soient produits et qui se retrouvent en
fin de vie donc comment on peut mieux
créer des emballages quels sont les
gestes de design qu'on pourrait faire
pour que les emballages soient moins
impacts donc il y a trois principes les
trois r qu'on connaît la réduction la
réutilisation réemploi et la
recyclabilité donc ces éléments-là sont
importants pour que on puisse agir avant
que les emballages soient reproduits à
des centaines d'exemplaires donc c'est
un peu l'idée de changer un peu le focus
sur le gâchis et peut-être regarder en
amont où est-ce qu'on pourrait faire
pour réduire le problème mais vous vous
êtes professeur vous vous intéressez à
cette chose-là est-ce que les
entreprises s'y intéressent est-ce qu'il
y a de plus en plus déco conception
est-ce que c'est à elle les entreprises
d'amorcer le virage ou c'est les
consommateurs qui doivent dire ben moi
je me tourne vers du vrac par exemple il
doit venir d'où l'effort mais en fait je
trouve que c'est cette question là est
souvent posée puis c'est comme si on
cherchait un peu un coupable ou
quelqu'un qui pourrait résoudre le
problème mais en fait on est tous dans
cette même histoire là parce que
l'emballage ça fait partie d'un système
d'un système complexe de distribution de
consommation puis tu vas être vie et
donc tout le monde est interpellé dans
tout ça et devrait travailler ensemble
donc oui je pense que les entreprises
déjà font quand même certains efforts
ils s'en vont moins parce que on peut
toujours pointer sur les parties moins
performantes mais c'est vrai que il y a
beaucoup d'efforts présentement et c'est
de plus en plus convenu et compris dans
les entreprises qu'il faut faire un
effort maintenant est-ce qu'on en fait
assez je pense qu'il reste beaucoup de
travail à faire et puis je pense que il
y a entre autres au niveau des
gouvernements puis des
pays des municipalités qu'on devrait
vraiment se poser des questions et
vraiment commencer à peut-être créer des
lois et des règlements pour normer tout
ça et même je me posais la question en
visionnant le documentaire est-ce qu'on
devrait pas aider les consommateurs à
faire de meilleurs choix avec des logos
par exemple ou des certifications qui
nous permettraient de nous de savoir
quand on fait l'épicerie au Québec tel
produit là j'ai moins nuisible par
exemple ça aiderait
des citoyens des consommateurs qui
peuvent pas être des spécialistes en
éco-conception on peut pas leur demander
ça donc il faut vraiment les aider le
design par définition son rôle c'est de
simplifier la vidéo et d'améliorer la
qualité de vie des gens donc
effectivement si on pouvait trouver des
systèmes normés des systèmes graphiques
qui nous aideraient peut-être à
reconnaître les bons des mauvaises
emballages mais peut-être qu'il y aura
un incitatif aussi pour les compagnies
de choisir les bonnes options pour
qu'elles soient vendues puis que les
citoyens les reconnaissent l'emballage
parfait monsieur alors c'est quoi
c'est en fait celui qu'on produit on
aimerait qu'il y ait pas d'emballage
mais on n'a pas le choix sinon on doit
s'inspirer de la nature à une coquille
d'oeuf la peau d'une banane ce sont des
emballages parfait bien sûr on est loin
de ça bien sûr on doit en avoir mais
l'emballage parfait c'est celui qui est
là juste quantité de matière pour la
bonne fonction pas plus pas moins pas
sur emballage
quelqu'un a noté qu'on le découvre
d'ailleurs dans le documentaire que vous
organisez des concours où des jeunes des
étudiants participent et innovent pour
tenter de trouver des matériaux
d'emballage plus respectueux de
l'environnement alors vraiment je vous
invite à le visionner merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous monsieur là
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI